steve irwin's lookalike son robert aims  to continue his late dad's legacy the 12  year old wildlife enthusiast revealed on  the Australia Today Show Saturday he  aims to follow in his father's footsteps  my dad was the original wildlife warrior  he was the most incredible wildlife  conservation and every single day we  strive to continue in his legacy  the young wildlife warrior seems to be  heading in the right direction how cool  is that  as Robert is nominated for a kids Emmy  Award for co-hosting a wildlife series  called wild but true we get to carry on  where he left off and we certainly  really enjoy it Robert isn't the only  Irwin kid pursuing a similar path as the  late legend Vinny Irwin has been vocal  about carrying on Steve's legacy he's a  huge part of my journey in life  you